scheiße bank verklagt worden
so und da sind wir wieder zurück
einfach jetzt hallo und herzlich
willkommen zurück in der türkei zusammen
mit lena und den ort und wir hatten
gerade ein paar problemchen
beziehungsweise denen die probleme in
meinem haus und damit meine ich noch
darüber sprach der hier drin war und
immer noch im netz hätte man euch die
festung gefunden aber wir sind schon
zwei dinge teile in die quere gekommen
aber ich habe aber auch schon ein
bracelet aber noch nicht den spanner
gefunden und ich frage dich kaputt
ja wenn ich absolut das gefühl hatte ich
auch auf einmal in die ganze schafe
falsch gefärbt und so sieht man erklärt
treiber dieser kümmerst du dich nicht
lieber um dem hause wirklich materialien
spross dann frag doch einfach ich habe
mich die hölle waikiki mich hier ab und
ich bin auf diesem langsamen satz sein
holz nach pflanzen oder bisher und nicht
in unserem angelegten bald der der läuft
hinter das ist geräte mit schwertern
durchsetzt den plan am rand von meinem
fernsehen die sind voll steht einer ich
bin ich bin schwarze herzlich im
schwarzen herzen ja damit sofern
terrorist heißt du stirbst darauf sagen
du bist du bist tot landschaft
du bist vor ganz nicht auf emst nicht
verfolgen diese skelette fan bist dort
tombstone wie felix post durch kommt zu
der stelle und sein 19
ich habe 28
in der nächsten woche noch ein paar
monster schlachten und dann da bin ich
jetzt echt am sterben weil ich hab ich
grad eingebaut
naja irgendwann einer sauna was gibst du
kannst nicht sterben ich glaube aber
nicht beim working papers und inhaltlich
so von ihn zu töten ich hab ihn hinter
einer wand gebaut und ich steh auf der
wand drauf und er kriegt mich nicht
total und produkte wie valensina flug
erfolg reden muss dollar oder witzbold
war richtig krank den du glaubst nicht
was ich durchmache ja nie so gut vom tod
zweite hürde und hat bisher nur zwei
kohle und knochen bekommen dann kann
sich besucher in den das ausbringen was
was er halt stopp was bringt mir denn
dann wird das wenn leute vorher machen
wenn du in twitter der wg stark stark
nicht doch da ist 1 ich höre die als
sandy um ihr wollt mit meinem gern
rezitiert war
die schießt der feier nein passt das
einfach so gemein von den gar nicht
nachvollziehen
aber so eine liebenswürdige person mit
ich einfach schießen das nicht hoffen
das ist doof vor allem sein triple drei
kombis oder sowas ja mindestens und 560
sieben toren
keine ahnung
patrick sollte man jetzt die poststelle
ich da nicht so weit weg kommunizieren
möchte ich doch nur töten
das sonderangebot machten auch nicht ich
finde das auch doof wenn du das machst
du kannst das dürfe man jetzt noch thema
dem thema der bieten
was hat er gesagt
die stadt aber was halt die idee von
haustieren habt habt über auch die
macher sind betroffen
also ich hatte mal haustiere exoten
urlaub kannst du etwas dazu sagen ich
werde auch wenn ich dazu sage es nicht
gut
was haltet ihr von galileo das haben wir
schon vor drei männer hier bei mir um zu
schauen ob ihr geister sind oder dass
nur einen grünen oder bist der mann bis
unterstützen was haltet ihr von galileo
lag gerade passiert denn wenn ich jetzt
total verbindet scriba man mitten am tag
was haltet ihr von galileo also was ich
dazu sagen kann ist dass na ja es wird
ja immer so dargestellt als ob das klug
wäre
ja und vieles ist dann stellt sich dann
also nee was aber sagt ich würde immer
so als total aufgebauscht dass irgendwas
aber auch schon ewigkeiten mehr geschaut
deswegen kann ich da nicht genau zu
sagen wie es im moment ist aber als das
früher gesehen habe und da immer wieder
sachen die schon vor zwei jahren gezeigt
habe und dann wieder der große töne und
wieder die größte pizza und wieder
einmal und an ein riesenschnitzel mit
dem riesen traktor mit diesen fetten
sechster vor und bot als wenn ich mir
das immer so angucke die recht warum
können leute immer noch glauben dass du
da wirklich was lernen was lärm an der
spitze der wälder wilde zwar nie zu
gesicht bekommen und werde jetzt schon
von dieser nachrichten profitiert werden
können galileo
wer hat hier unten die sachen weg
gemacht bei mir im haus hat jemand von
euch die weg gemacht
nur ob ich habe ich war gar nicht im
rahmen sind von der wand gefallen
da bin ich froh wenn ich sonst auch
länder die erschütterung jahrhundertes
weggesprengt oder wie ja dann kleine
kinder dollar eingebracht
scheiße bagger sind schon wieder zwei
von diesen scheiß riesiges glätten oder
denn die die wasserrutsche mit looping
oder saßen dann wird er wieder zehn
minuten werbungen dann kommt wieder
sagen das war und wird er den looping
schaffen war sah ich mag solche noch
nicht so gerne aber wie sieht es mit
euch aus
ich finde ich
wie schon gesagt kann ich mich nur
anschließen doch noch mehr aus afrika
wikileaks das war gar nicht so gemeint
ja so warte ich muss grad mich grad ein
bisschen darauf konzentrieren welche ist
schon wieder so eine scheiße let s
letzten stein schwert fallen acom ich
bitte euch mit seinen bildern den kopf
die das wirklich mit den skeletten aber
ich stark und schnell der schwerer haben
ich dachte es noch schlimmer
fast genauso wissen und schlimmer vor
allem schlimmer ist es wirklich braucht
unbedingt heute knöpfe muss jetzt nichts
gescheites skeletten ist es darunter
gefallen noch hinterher
lediglich anfang zu bauen also ich kann
aus zwei jahren von den anderen sagen
dass dies weißen zeitdruck hatten
roboter schon wieder so einen scheiß
ding jedoch einfach weg bitte sowie der
zeitdruck in den klausuren wenn man am
anfang zu wenig gemacht und am ende
immer noch am ende alles ganz schnell
machen muss und werden und dann denkt
man fragt man sich nachher warum man so
schlecht war
obwohl ich habe heute eine klausur
zurück bekommt und es war eine zwei in
englisch sei sehr froh drüber
das geld kann feuer aushalten
ja komm hoch ziffern bastelt man steht
hier unten rum
und schon wieder kohle und ein knochen
haye war richtig geil
warum ist wollte diese place teile
finden ich habe zwar ein aber ich will
es trotzdem finden weil ich will ganz
viele extreme hasse das wenn ich s p
habe ich habe nicht die boarder hinten
geht weiter die fans riesig und dann
habe ich immer so gibt es das befürchtet
dass befürchtung dass denning und
sterben und sie den ganzen weg und
deswegen jetzt folgen so eine expertin
der sauna unter sommers werden passiert
also davor angst das kann ich gar nicht
verstehen er keine rolle verstehen der
trainer sagen uns die ganzen leute
haltet euch mal wieder betteln wir uns
männern verfolgt mit dem treuen verstehe
ich sogar schule geschrieben
überlasst das toll die papis medica wäre
schon ein fall der ihm ist sein und die
handtasche reviews 1 series und den aber
ich komme ja ich komme wieder nichts ich
sortiere mal hin ein bisschen aber ich
weiß nicht bauen soll was ich bauen soll
das ist natürlich schlecht das könnte
ich wende gehen er wird jetzt kann ich
finde jeder war eine treppe treffe ich
dachte schon hinter mir und dann sehe
ich oder sowieso eine ecke denkt okay
ich bin sicher obama hat schon wieder 1
also bei mir läuft irgendwie einige male
bei mir ist das ziemlich interessant
jackpot bitte nein es ist so weit über
mir da ein
ich brenne darin ist der eingangsbereich
und gehe ich hier so rein und dann ist
da ein fernseher da sofa
unglaublich hat madame redstone
feuerwehren thema galileo wirst du
gesagt ja ich zweifel an der an der
legitimität der gezeigten sachen bzw ich
zweifele ich weiß dass die sache mit
ihnen nicht stimmt und auch schon
tausend mal gesendet wurden ua von
überall kommen sie ja stimmten sie
meistens schon aber relativ belanglos
oder wenn sie irgendwelche webvideos ist
das ein fake ja oder nein galiläa macht
in 45 minuten mit vier langen
unterbrechungen den ultimativen fake
check unnötig von allen seiten die
russin auch tot und er dass die ganzen
xp schön und lava fallen sehr geil
irgendwann sollte anders
was irgend was ist heute anders hier
warum die russen kommen lange soll ich
heute hier
nein ich bin nur total aufgebracht weil
ich im never been und von überall kommen
bobs ich muss ich habe echt angst dass
ich richtig verrecke und richtig auf die
schnauze kriege und nur da war es hat
immerhin schon mal angefangen zu bauen
ja ich habe kräftig selbst ungefähr
willst du denn jetzt bauen
da wurde das meinte beim wasser wasser
ist etwas was man gut
verstehst du da unten ein skelett damit
eine hafenanbindung hast mit deiner
stadt ibadan errichten wirst mich
irgendwann mal schlafen oder nicht muss
ich bin im letter werde ich das schlaf
ist nicht so geil
doch baumann better place eschborner
gefunden dingsbums noch warum bleibt
nicht mehr zwei gefunden direkt
nebeneinander er warum bleibst du nicht
mal bei einem ich habe zwei gefühl das
ist der erste den ich gefunden habe
ich dachte wartet schon ein nein überall
herum geflogen aber er kann ich die
koordinaten hier sehe ich das nicht
80 und 300 der bindemittel werde das
seht 80 und 300 bedingungen darauf
schreiben bzw bitte diese kommentare in
die kommentare schreiben
diese koordinaten die kommentare
schreiben wer genau
danke
wenn wir jetzt geld nur geil geil ich
liebe leute ganztagsschule kein geld
hast du noch kein glaube ich mir das
verlieren von warte ich werde jetzt
einfach mal hier ich hab erst die hülle
gefunden wo wir in der ersten nacht man
ich ja voll da wo wusste ich gar nicht
mehr
von romi nicht ich habe 28 1 halb level
wie viele muss ich dann auch tote waren
wir nach meiner ersten geht es hier und
da waren wir noch meine ersten acht
seiner komischen höhle einer komischen
groß und würden so eingebaut hat steffen
krieb an ihn
ich hab ein level und gehen und zurück
13 uhr
zu wenig wird die von allen seiten
abgeschossene ich weiß nicht mehr wo er
gut das portal ist ja beim zurücklaufen
nicht weiter ich bin von der fakt dass
wir so einen scheiß skelettiert 28 und
ein bisschen und zwei tunnel fast schon
ich brauche mir mit mehr monster hier
mit komma ist die spinne hier riecht als
das stück kavelstorf hat klar nein
die vollkommen scheiße [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] war verraten wo ich habe mir nie so
erschreckt da ist ein schwarzes gerät
vor mir kommt als von hinter mir an
ich habe mich nie so erschreckt
wird aus passen musste ich bin vater
gestorben ist so dass sich dank etwas
für spur
das liegt wohl an altersdemenz aus dem
hinterhalt überraschend münzen eric und
ich hab immer noch nicht zum blöden kopf
jetzt was viele schon ungefähr sieben
von ihnen getötet
die laufen
wir sollten da kann einer von euch
kosten etwa geht über die koordinaten
von portal sagen jetzt bin ich relativ
viel zu weit weg davon was ich alles
okay ich habe es gefunden ich habe
gefragt was soll ich über fett zu
bezahlen und das buch dann anzuwenden
und dann richtig das heißt ich muss ein
paar bucht reinpacken in den airbus und
dann dann kann ich auswählen was sie
drauf haben will
das muss ist trotzdem zufällig
aber dann kann das buch hat auch mit
seinem schwert kombinieren was dann auf
dem schwert zum beispiel sharpless 50
patronen ja aber wenn du wenn du ein
buch mit bällen auf dings bekommst du
hast du auch verkackt würde nicht also
was ist denn der große vorteil so alles
immer noch zufällig dass du nicht
jemanden finden der formensprache
ja aber nur wenn man wenn man nicht
dauernd stirbt also dann auch aber dann
ist es nicht so dass man so viel im
überfluss davon hat wahrscheinlich weil
ich mein einziger bisheriger wanne
aber ich bin der einzige der diese
komische festung da gesehen hat und ich
habe es floss ich habe war ich kann sie
im inventar gucken wir in diesem
komischen portal da verstecken sind
übrigens schon wieder bei 17 minuten in
folge freunde bis zum nächsten mal